Die Rechtsgrundlage bleibt dieselbe.
Na klar, weil also mit Abfangen und mit Ausspähen...
Das ist auch schon 202 übrigens. Also 202a und 202b gibt es auch. Da gibt es übrigens eine lustige Anekdote zu zur Clubgründung. Also wir erzählen uns manchmal, dass der Club bei der Schaffung von Paragraph 202 vor der Auswahl stand, als kriminelle Vereinigung oder als eingetragener Verein weiterzuarbeiten. Und dann haben wir halt den Verein gewählt. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen apokriffisch. Aber ich meine, ja, der Hackertool-Paragraph ist schon echt alt. Und das ist im Moment schon, also was heißt im Moment schon, vor dem 202c so gewesen, dass der Angriff auf den PC verboten war. Aber jetzt ist quasi schon das davor verboten. Jetzt möchten sie quasi die Vorbereitungshandlung verbieten und kriegen keine gute Definition dafür hin und sagen deswegen der Besitz von einem Tool.
Aber wenn das Gesetz so gelöchrig und so schwammig ist, wie ist es dann durchgegangen?
Naja, wir haben in der Veröffentlichung schon mal versucht zu erklären. So eine richtig gute Antwort haben wir nicht drauf. Meine persönliche Vermutung ist schlicht, dass ein gewisserzeitlicher Druck hinter war, weil eben die Cybercrime Convention umgesetzt werden musste und dass sie vom Tisch haben wollten. Auch, dass natürlich Teile der Mitglieder des Rechtsausschusses die technischen Details nicht durchschaut haben. Und dann kommt dazu, dass im Bundestag ja heute nicht mehr wirklich nach Sachlage entschieden wird, sondern nach Fraktionszwang. Und mir hat sich im Rechtsausschuss die... Eigentlich hat sich bei mir die Meinung aufgedrängt, dass vorher schon klar war. Lass sie mal erzählen, die Experten hier. Wir haben eigentlich schon beschlossen, dass es durchgeht. Augen zu und durch. Und da schreiben wir halt noch eine komische Begründung dran, die so ein bisschen relativiert. So war mein Eindruck. Man kann das anders sehen. Wir haben ja vorhin auch schon darüber gesprochen. Meine persönliche Meinung ist, dass da einfach auch wenig Interesse daran war und dass die Probleme, die da auf uns zukommen, überhaupt nicht gesehen wurden.
Diese ganze Diskussion, die wir jetzt hier auch führen und die viele Experten führen, Felix hat vorhin auch von BSI erzählt, die quasi eine eigene Bundesbehörde oder jemand, der für eine Bundesbehörde arbeitet, die selbst sagen, das Gesetz betrifft uns dann hier auch. Also im Haus würde es Probleme geben. Gibt es da irgendwelche Reaktionen auf den, wir werden es verändern oder wir werden es zurücknehmen? Oder ist das Gesetz jetzt da und bleibt es?
Na ja, es gab schon, als das in Kraft trat, oder kurz vor dem Krafttreten am 11. August letzten Jahres, gab es schon eine Menge Stellungnahmen. Das heißt, so die offiziellen Verbände wie die Bitkom oder der Eco-Verband, also die jetzt industrienah sind, die haben sich dann geäußert. Natürlich, klar, da gab es Widerstand. Es gab auch Firmen jetzt aus dem IT-Security-Bereich, die sich einzeln dazu geäußert haben und auch noch mal teilweise Stellungnahmen abgegeben haben. Eigentlich haben alle so ein bisschen erwartet, wann kommt der Erste, der die Befassungsbeschwerde macht. Die ist ja tatsächlich auch schon im Oktober geschrieben worden. Das heißt, relativ schnell nach dem Gesetz haben sich dann Leute an den Anwalt gewandt und versucht, Befassungsbeschwerde einzulegen. Und jetzt, momentan, haben wir ja sogar noch eine zweite Befassungsbeschwerde, die kommt aus dem universitären Bereich, wo einfach die Einschränkung der Lehre da auch noch mal möglichst angegriffen wird von dem Beschwerdeführer.
Weil, was du vorhin auch schon erzählt hast, dass an Universitäten gar nicht mehr unterrichtet werden kann, Leute gar nicht mehr ausgebildet werden können.
Das ist aber nicht nur Uni. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch eine Menge Zuschriften beim CCC. Wir kriegen immer so allerhand Mails, meistens ziemlich kritische zu Sachen, zu denen wir uns äußern. Und da war es besonders der Berufsausbildungsbereich, dass eben Berufsschüler, die irgendeine Form von Fachinformatiker werden, dass sie etwa von ihren Lehrenden dann gesagt bekommen, also früher haben wir hier noch praktisch Übungen gemacht, aber jetzt sagen wir, dass ihr euch ja irgendwie an eurer Freizeit aneignet, oder besser noch gar nicht, denn ihr macht euch ja da stafbar. Das hören wir von den jungen Berufsausbildenden. Das hören wir öfter.
Ja, wir können auch mal kurz erzählen. Also wir reden ja auch gelegentlich mit Politikern.
Warte mal, lass mich kurz mit Sven fragen, ob damit seine Frage beantwortet ist. Sven, bist du noch da?
Ja, ich bin noch da und meine Frage ist, dass man so weit beantwortet. Und ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin gelernter IT-Systemaktueuriker.
Du hast den Nullschuld. Was bist du gelernter?
IT-Systemaktueuriker.
Ah, Glückwunsch.
Hast du denn bei dir in der Lehre irgendwie betroffen oder ist das schon länger her?
Nee, ich habe jetzt auch frisch ausgelernt und ich bin davon nicht betroffen, muss ich sagen. In unserem Beruf hat man doch vieles gemacht, was nicht legal war. Aber das war halt alles gut am Zwischen. Da ist es aber normal, denke ich mal.
Und meinst du, das bleibt so? Habt ihr darüber gesprochen?
Nicht wirklich darüber gesprochen und ich denke mal, das bleibt auf jeden Fall so, weil die Lehrer sind alles ältere Lehrer. Die haben doch alles mit, sag ich mal, irgendwelchen älteren Programmen zu tun gehabt. Und wir jungen Schüler, sag ich mal, haben dann die neuen Programme mit eingefügt und somit haben wir uns irgendwo zusammen gewonnen und dadurch hat das genau kommuniziert.
Findest du das doch okay so oder denkst du manchmal, da wird kriminellen Aktivitäten vielleicht Vorschub geleistet?
Ah, ich denke mal, das ist okay. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, dass die Sätze vielleicht blöd sind in meinen Augen. Und dass wir irgendwie setzen, was die Politiker irgendwie gemacht haben, weil sie das machen wollten. Und ja, ich denke, das wird so weiterhin bleiben, auf jeden Fall.
Wärst du denn froh, wenn das Fassungsgericht in Karlsruhe sagt, ach nö, wollen wir nicht, das ist verpassungswidrig?
Ja, wir setzen sich, das ist ideal. Ich mache trotzdem...
Die ist ideal, deine Ausbildung ist jetzt noch durch.
Genau, und die können wir voll durch, die durch den weiteren machen werden, denke ich mal.
Ja, aber Sekunde, du willst ja erst in dem Beruf arbeiten, nicht wahr?
Ja.
Na ja, und wenn du mal in eine größere Firma gehst, dann hast du da auch eine Rechtsabteilung im Nacken, das ist dir schon klar, oder?
Ich mache jetzt zwar etwas anderes, erst mal eine Weile, aber es ist schon klar, aber irgendwo denke ich mal, ich war in einer kleineren Firma mit 20-25 Mann, und da haben wir trotzdem weiterhin so gemacht. Du musst es ja irgendwo machen, den Kunden, du musst ja die Kunden halten. Wenn du mal sagst, das geht nicht und so weiter, und wir können das nicht, warum setzt ihr, dann suchen sich irgendwelche anderen, die das können.
Deutschlands Computerexperten, eine Horde Straftäter.
Ja, wir stehen alle mit einem Bein im Knast. Ja, also wir reden ja schon mit Politikern gelegentlich, und wir fragen natürlich auch, wie kommt es, dass so ein Gesetz durchkommt. Und was wir da häufig hören, ist, naja, es ist ja noch keiner im Knast deswegen.
Und was ist eigentlich ein Browser?
Also das System funktioniert, ja gut, das kommt auch, aber der Zirkelschluss ist an der Stelle perfekt, denn die sagen sozusagen, naja, es ist ja noch keiner zu Unrecht verhaftet worden, also funktioniert ja unser System, und dann können wir das Gesetz auch lassen. Das heißt, wir haben ein Gesetz, das im Grunde Latent halb Deutschland im Knast stellt. Ja, aber das macht ja nichts, weil die Richter machen das bisher nicht. Also quasi völlig unglaublich.
Aber die Richter entscheiden nicht, weil die Rechtslage unklar ist, und sie fällen keine Entscheidung, und die Rechtslage bleibt unklar, weil die Richter keine Entscheidung fällen. Das Ding dreht sich jetzt immer um sich selber.
Genau, so dreht sich das um sich selber. Und normalerweise macht man aus genau diesem Grund, also was heißt man, aber die Amerikaner machen das so, dass sie ein Gesetz erst mal nur für ein Jahr erlassen. Also das gibt es ja auch selten.
Gibt's.
Aber das gibt's. Und das heißt, das Gesetz, wenn es nach einem Jahr nicht wieder bestätigt wird, ist es automatisch wieder weg.
Hat quasi einen Verfallsdatum.
Genau.
Und das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee. Weil das heißt, wenn sich zeigt, dass wir das nie gebraucht haben, das Gesetz, dann können wir es auch wieder wegschmeißen. Find ich eine gute Sache.
Ein Gesetzbuch mit Löschroutieren.
Entschuldigung, meine Herren. Da möchte ich immer mal einwenden, dass es eigentlich so ist, dass der Gesetzgeber vorab prüfen muss, ob dieses Gesetz Sinn macht. Er muss es sinnvoll begründen. Es ist nicht so, dass... Man ist jetzt zwar daran gewöhnt, dass wir so professionelle, ich sag mal, auf Deutsch zu sagen, Gesetzesverkacke haben und dass viele Gesetze gekippt werden. Aber eigentlich müsste unser verfassungsgebender Organ und gesetzgebender Organ eben der Bundestag vorher prüfen, ob ein Gesetz okay ist. Also fangen wir nicht an, nur weil die da gerade keine guten Gesetze machen, da die Standards nach unten zu setzen.
Nein, so was ist doch nicht gemeint. Aber wir könnten zumindest diesen Notanker, den finde ich schon an sich eine gute Idee. Also das ist auch so ein Trend in der Rangehensweise von Programmieren, Extreme Programming, da sagt man, Fehler werden halt gemacht. Und dann müssen wir eben dafür sorgen, dass sie korrigiert werden. Gut, bei Gesetzen sollte es nicht so sein.
Aber jetzt stell dir bitte vor...
Ladies and Gentlemen, bevor wir jetzt hier über die Gesetzgebung in Deutschland an sich diskutieren, schlage ich vor, wir atmen alle drei Minuten durch, hören die Co-Letment No Government und dann diskutieren wir mit euch weiter unter 0331 70 97 110 über Paragraph 202 Strafgesetzbuch, den Hacker Paragraphen im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Schnieke Musik hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Nicolette, No Government. Die Frau kennt ihr vielleicht von einigen Massive Attack Platten. Wir haben es gleich viertel zwölf. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio auf Fritz mit Fefe, mit Konz. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir telefonieren und reden und diskutieren mit euch unter 0331 70 97 110. Und es geht um den ominösen Hacker- Paragraphen. Wir haben in der letzten Stunde schon mit mehreren Beispielen erwähnt, warum dieser Paragraph ziemlicher Mumpitz ist und warum dieses Gesetz auf so dünnem Eis steht. Der nächste am Telefon ist Johannes, der uns ordentlich die Leviten lesen will. Wir haben nämlich Unsinn erzählt. Hallo, Johannes.
Die ganze Backup-Geschichte ist schon ein bisschen länger her, als ihr behauptet habt, dass ältere Backup für einzuspielen, auf denen diese Tools vorhanden sind, auch nicht so ganz legal wäre oder dass man damit Probleme bekommen könnte. Es nicht wirklich war, weil der Besitz an sich, der Hacker-Tools, wollte ich nur ganz kurz berichtigen, selber nicht illegal ist. Also wenn, ich weiß nicht, dass der 202c vor einem Jahr ungefähr in Kraft getreten muss, wenn die Backups älter als ein Jahr sind.
Na ja, die Frage ist, also du hast Recht, der Besitz ist nicht verboten, aber dass sich verschaffen ist verboten. Wenn du dir jetzt ein Tape aus dem Schrank holst von 1980 und holst dir da ein Telnet runter, oder was weiß ich, ein Angriffstool, dann könnte man ja argumentieren, dass es sich verschaffen ist. Weil du hast es vorher nicht auf deinem Rechner gehabt, aber danach hast du es auf dem Rechner.
Aber ich habe es besessen.
Na ja, aber in einer Form, die du nicht ausführen konntest vorher.
Verschaffen ist, dass ich den Besitz erschaffe. Also jetzt nicht physikalisch das Ding aus dem Schrank holen.
Na ja, pass mal auf, die Linie ist nicht so einfach. Es gab mal vor vielen Jahren eine CD zu kaufen mit lauter verschlüsselten Programmen drauf und da hat man dann eins gekauft und dann haben die einem den Key zugeschickt und damit hat man das entschlüsselt. Und da hätte man genauso argumentieren können mit dem Backup jetzt. Wieso war doch in meinem Besitz? Also das ist nicht so einfach, wie du es hier gerade machst. Da kann man lange und ausgiebig drüber streiten.
Nein, nein, also ich würde schon sagen, dass du im Wesentlichen Recht hast. Man kann sich natürlich ein paar Spezialfälle kreieren, wo Besitz nicht so ganz klar ist, also wo der Unterschied zwischen zugänglich machen, verschaffen und Besitz nicht klar ist. Im Wesentlichen würde ich schon sagen, das stimmt, weil im Gesetz steht auch nicht besitzen, sondern eben nur herstellen, sich verschaffen, verkaufen, überlassen, verbreiten oder zugänglich machen. Und insofern hast du dem Wortlaut nach auf jeden Fall recht.
Das heißt, wenn die IT-Firma, die Sicherheitsfirma ein Giftschrank hat, wo all die bösen, bösen Viren drin sind, besitzen sie sie nur und damit kann ihnen noch keiner was.
Wenn sie sie nicht hergestellt haben.
Und sich auch nicht verschafft haben, was ja ein bisschen schwierig in der Beweislage dann wahrscheinlich sein wird.
Verwachtmeister, die waren einfach da.
Die haben da halt, die hat Captain Kirk runtergebeamt.
Das ist wie mit den Filmen nachts, die man dann morgens auf der Festplatte findet. Die sind einfach da.
Du hast Filme auf der Festplatte?
Ja, kennst du das nicht, dass du manchmal morgens irgendwie den Computer aufklappst und wieder neue Filme da?
Ich hab immer nur Kaffeetassen-Ränder auf der Festplatte.
Also Johannes, wir wollen uns natürlich für den Hinweis bedanken. Also wenn wir dir ein bisschen flapsig ausgedrückt haben, ich denke schon, dass du zumindest, was den Wortlaut betrifft, auf jeden Fall recht hast und in vielen Details wohl auch und nur in einigen Spezialfällen das nicht so ganz klar wäre.
Also nur generell, solange die Dinge eben älter sind, hat man da ein Jahr Sinn, de facto anscheinend nicht zu befrechten.
Aber wenn du deinen Backup outgesourct hast und du rufst jetzt die Firma an, bring mir doch mal das Tape von 2004.
Dann haben die ein Problem, weil sonst...
Na ja, aber ich meine, da ist ein Problem, würde ich damit sagen. Ist ja wurscht.
Fühlst du dich denn sonst irgendwie betroffen? Also was hältst du denn von den Paragraphen so?
Ja gut, dass es schmarrn ist, dann muss man eigentlich nicht drüber reden.
Also du würdest dich auch freuen, wenn Karlsruhe sagt, auch nö.
Naja, selber betroffen bin ich es noch nicht wirklich, aber das kommt dann spätestens im Vertiefungsstudium, denke ich.
Dann wünschen wir dir viel Glück, einen wunderbaren Sommer und immer eine weiße Weste.
Nicht Glück, Erfolg wünschen wir.
Danke Johannes, tschüss. Der nächste am Telefon ist Konstantin, der einen sehr interessanten Einwurf hat. Hallo Konstantin.
Ja hallo. Wenn es jetzt legal ist, die Dinger zu besitzen, was ist, wenn ich jetzt ein Virus zugeschickt kriege oder irgendeine Software, die sich selbstständig verbreitet und weiterschickt? Führt die sich ja gleichzeitig auch aus?
Du, ohne dein Zutun?
Naja, ich muss ja irgendwas aufrufen, auspasehen, dass die sich ausführt, aber sie führt sich aus. Und ich bin ja im Grunde dann schuld daran und mache mich ja damit strafbar, obwohl ich gar nichts davon wusste.
Meinst du jetzt die Verbreitung, also dass du sie verbreitest?
Naja, da bist du auf jeden Fall dran, wenn die Software, wenn es ein Virus ist, und der verkopiert sich weiter an andere Leute. Also theoretisch ja, in der Praxis ist es so, dass wir das ja schon länger haben, dass Viren praktisch verboten sind, dass sind ja schon Leute für belangt worden. Allerdings gibt es auch den Gegenfall, und der ist deutlich häufiger in der Rechtsprechung, dass Leute aus Sachen rauskommen, weil sie sagen, den habe ich aber nicht installiert, sondern der hat sich von alleine installiert. Also es gab auch sogar jemanden, der aus einem Kinderporno-Fall rausgekommen ist, mit der Begründung, dass habe ich ein Virus installiert. Der hätte das gedownloadet, und das wäre es gar nicht gewesen. Also im Zweifelsfall, wenn der Richter verstehen kann, dass du die Software nicht installiert hast, würde ich mir privat jetzt keine Sorgen machen, aber das ist durchaus ein Spannungsfeld, da würde ich dir Recht geben.
Und wie ist das in sich, wenn ich da ein Skript in meinen Web 3.0 Dienst eintippe, ist das dann schon ein Programm, was ich erzeugt habe, dadurch, dass ich da alles Mögliche weiter arbeite.
Kannst du mal bitte mit einem konkreten Beispiel das Ganze unterbauen?
Naja, man muss sich schon vergegenwärtigen, dass Angriffssoftware jetzt nicht immer große Software ist, sondern dass so ein Exploit, und wir haben beispielhaft einen in unserer Stellungnahme, auch schon mal ein Einzeiler sein kann. Also was heißt, ein Angriffstool muss nicht eben lang und breit sein und kann durchaus einen kleinen Skript schon hergeben, durchaus.
Ja, das habe ich nämlich auch den Fall gesehen, dass ich festgestellt habe, dass es möglich ist, bei einem System bei uns in der Nähe, also hier aus Görlitz, gibt es so einen Web 2.0-Dienst. Und da war es möglich, Skript auszuführen per Nachrichten. Und da habe ich dann mit Minden mal geschrieben, der hat es erst noch mal im Jahr dann gefixt, aber da habe ich auch so ein Problem gesehen.
Ich glaube, das ist auch ein ganz gutes Beispiel eigentlich.
Ja, und Kettenmails sind ja an sich auch so eine Sache.
Ja, da haben wir auch schon vorhin beim Abendessen darüber diskutiert, ob man nicht auch ein Nigeria-Scam als Angriffssoftware werten kann. Die hackt dann zwar nicht den Rechner, sondern das Hirn, den User. Aber gut, das ist jetzt natürlich nicht gemeint mit dem Gesetz. Und da wird wahrscheinlich auch der Richter sagen, nein.
Ja, dafür wurde doch mal einer verhaftet, weil er halt übers Telefon die Passwörter herausgekriegt hat.
Ja, wo wir bei Passwörtern waren, da haben wir auch noch einen wichtigen Punkt, den wir noch erwähnen wollten.
Also, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute das mitbekommen haben, aber es gab ja doch eine ziemlich schwere Sicherheitslücke bei der Linienungsdistribution Debiagen. Und da haben wir mal ein Beispiel, wo es sich nicht um den Zweck von Software dreht, sondern um den anderen Fall, der in dem Paragraphen 202c drin ist, nämlich Passwortliste.
Wer eine Straftat vorbereitet, indem er Passwörter herstellt oder zugänglich macht?
Also, da muss ich auch eine kleine Anekdote erzählen aus dem Ausschuss, in dem er saß.
Warte mal, wir verabschieden erst einmal Konstantin in die Nacht. Das war ein großartiger Eingriff.
Ich wollte mal sagen, dass an sich wahrscheinlich der Computerbesitz strafbar ist und die Adresse...
Oh man, die Idee...
Ja, der Internet ist strafbar, Denken ist strafbar, gute Musik hören ist strafbar und nach 11 bei Fritz anrufen ist noch nicht strafbar.
Und die Adresseile im Browser oder sowieso der Browser ist ja auch ein Hacker-Tour.
Außer du gibst eine lange Telefonnummer ein. Kannst ja auch vielleicht irgendwas mit hacken.
Oder Nutzernamen von Telekom oder sowas.
Nur mit Telepartie anrufen.
So jung und schon so kriminell.
Ich wohne in einem Opal-Ghetto, da gibt es kein Internet.
So jetzt aber. Passwörter.
Genau, also das ist so die Formulierung, die du da vorgelesen hast, die ist auf vielen anderen aufgefallen und ich saß also in diesem Ausschuss im Bundestag und habe also eigentlich meine Argumente bringen wollen und das war natürlich auf meiner Liste drauf. Das Herstellen von Passwortlisten, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein.
Was ist eine Passwortliste?
Ja, das ist totaler Mumpitz. Also ich meine, was damit gemeint ist, ist wahrscheinlich, dass es Passwortcracker gibt, also Programme, die einfach ganz viele Passwörter ausprobieren, indem sie einfach ein Wörterbuch nehmen und ein bisschen narrieren und damit halt versuchen aus einem Hashtag, so speichert man heute Passwörter aus, das Passwort zu rekonstruieren. Also das ist eine Art von Angriffsstoffware und das hat das Gesetz wahrscheinlich gemeint. Aber was da steht, ist eben was anderes. Da steht das Herstellen an der Passwortliste und das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen Zettel nehme und da, sagen wir mal, meine Einkaufsliste raufschreibe, dann weiß doch keiner, ob das Passwörter sind oder nicht. Das heißt, theoretisch könnten jetzt Richter kommen und sagen, das sieht mir aus wie eine Passwortliste. Brot, Milch, Möhtüten, Herr Leitner. Ich hatte das fest vor in diesem Ausschuss anzusprechen und war der Dritte an der Reihe in der Liste. Alle vor mir haben das angesprochen und haben gesagt, das Schönste war, dass die Industrievertreter, die haben es versucht diplomatisch zu machen. Also ich bin ja eher so ein Typ, ich stelle mich hin und sage, das ist Blödsinn, das können sie so nicht machen. Das gibt keinen Sinn. Aber die Industrievertreter haben gesagt, das sieht schlecht für die gesetzgebende Instanz aus in unserem Lande, wenn ein Gesetz diese Formulierung fälschlicherweise enthält. Und dann könnte das Volk ihnen die Kompetenz absprechen.
Die sind einfach so seriös.
Ja, die sind halt seriöser, als ich das gerade schon sage.
So, aber nochmal, die Erstellung einer Passwortliste, mein Mozilla Browser macht nichts anderes, außer mich zu fragen, soll ich das Passwort speichern? Und ich sage, ja, mach mal. Ich mache das nämlich nicht. Und dann gibt es irgendwo eine Liste, wo ich sage, ah, das sind alle meine Passworte. Damit ist mein Mozilla strafbar oder ecke?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein grenzwertiges Beispiel ist. Bei dem Debian-Beispiel sieht man es ein bisschen besser. Denn um dieses Problem zu lösen, wenn man sich jetzt eine neue Debian holt, also diese Linux-Distribution, dann kriegt man halt diese Passwortliste mit, um zu checken, ob man irgendwelche Keys hat, die man nicht mehr benutzen sollte, weil sie unsicher sind. Das heißt, es hat eine Liste, eine 5-stellige Anzahl von Schlüsseln, die dann mitgeliefert wird. Man bekommt die also. Und das ist eindeutig eine Passwortliste, die man aber auch gleichzeitig dazu benutzen kann, um anzugreifende Computer auswendig zu machen. Etwa Banken oder Online-Shops kann man natürlich damit tun. Da kann sich aber erstmal der Benutzer auch nicht wehren, denn das ist eine ganz klassische sogenannte Dual-Use-Tool. Also diese Passwortliste kann eben zu einem guten Bildenzweck verwendet werden.
Also es gibt sogar noch ältere Beispiele. Es ist seit, weiß ich nicht, 20 Jahren üblich unter Unix, wenn man sein Passwort ändert, dass das Passwortender-Programm in einer Datenbank nachguckt, ob dieses Passwort leicht zu raten ist oder nicht. Und dazu gehört unter anderem eben auch, dass der in einer Wörterliste nachguckt, ob das direkt ein Wort aus einem Wörterbuch ist.
Das ist einfach um die Qualität zu sichern, damit man den User dazu zwingt.
Das gibt es nicht nur unter Unix, es gibt es in ganz vielen.
Ja, natürlich. Aber unter Unix ist es tatsächlich eine Textdatei, wo einfach die Passwörter drin stehen. Und damit ist völlig klar, das ist eine Passwortliste. Und die hat jemand erstellt und ich habe sie mir beschafft, indem ich Unix installiert habe. Und das ist strafbar.
Also das ist für mich auch noch bei vielen anderen Beispielen sichtbar. Ich habe zum Beispiel große Passwortlisten, die ich sammle, weil ich mich mit der Sicherheit von Passworten befasse. Ich habe zum Beispiel etwa mal, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das im Radio sagen darf, oder ob ich den schönen Strafband bin.
Ich mache mal kurz dein Mikrofon.
Ich habe zum Beispiel die Gesamtliste der User-Accounts und Passworte von MySpace. Denn die sind ja mehrfach gehackt worden, und die findet sich dann im Netz. Und weil es eine große Liste ist von vielen Millionen Passwörtern, kann man die sehr gut analysieren, hinsichtlich der Qualität der Passwörter.
Alles für die Wissenschaft. Das geht hier nicht ums Hacken.
Kronz musste umziehen, weil diese 400 Tonnen Papier irgendwo hinmuss.
Ja, ich habe die ja nicht ausgedruckt. Also das ist natürlich eine große Textdatei. Und natürlich darf ich die eigentlich nicht mehr haben. Denn klar, die kann man natürlich auch zu bösen Zwecken verwenden.
Na, eigentlich durftest du die vorher schon nicht haben. Das ist nämlich Ausspähen von Daten.
Nein, nein, ich habe sie nicht ausspäht. Ich habe mir die Datei runtergeladen.
Na, das kannst du ja mal nachweisen dann im Einfluss.
Okay, ich sehe die Problematik. Aber ich habe natürlich keine Passwerte ausgespäht. Ich habe mir nur die Textdatei geladen.
Wenn Sie da Fragen haben, dann rufen Sie einfach an 0331 70 97 110.
Gibt es hier eigentlich einen Hinterausgang?
Ja, da ist eine Schranke, wie du siehst. Zurück zum Thema. Der nächste am Telefon ist Martin. Hallo Martin, guten Abend. Martin, bist du noch da? Moment.
Du hast das Radio noch an, oder?
Genau, ich hatte das Radio noch an.
Wir haben dich ein bisschen überfahren. Wir haben dir nicht gesagt, dass du gleich dran bist. Aber jetzt bist du dran. Martin, grüß dich. Wie hast du deinen Mittwoch bis Langfeier gebracht? Wir haben ein bisschen geplenkelt, dass wir wieder reinkommen.
Was habe ich heute gemacht? Ich bin erst mal ausgeschlafen.
Also du bist ein Ferienmensch gerade.
Ja, genau.
Und keine Hackertour ist zwischendurch eingestellt?
Nein, das geht ja gerade nicht. Ich bin ja im Urlaub segeln.
Ach, hast du den Rechner nicht bei?
Aber du bist jetzt nicht 200 Seemeilen nördlich von Kaporn und rufst uns vom Satellitentelefon an und hast schon 500 Dollar verbaraten? Nein.
Nein, bin ich nicht. Ich bin in Mecklenburg.
So, jetzt deine Frage.
Also meine Frage wäre jetzt gewesen, ob XFire auch so ein Angriffstool ist.
Was ist XFire?
XFire ist Software für Spiele. Also es geht mir jetzt ja hauptsächlich um die Studiengänge oder Arbeit oder so. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel ein Spiel im Internet spielt, kann man Programme XFire installieren, so. Und da kann man jetzt sehen, wie lange jemand zum Beispiel im Internet war und dieses und jenes Spiel gespielt hat. Und andere können das bei dir auch sehen. Und gleichzeitig überprüft dieses Programm immer wieder, ob dein Spiel auch original ist. So ist das jetzt auch ein Angriffstool?
Nee, du hast ja da, du riechst jetzt ja keinen Schaden an. Also das wäre höchstens Ausspähen von Daten, wenn da nicht sowieso eine Schnittstelle wäre, um an diese Informationen ranzukommen. Und die existiert ja offensichtlich. Also da würde ich mir jetzt keine Sorgen machen.
Wie stellst du dir denn den Angriff vor? Also wie würdest du damit einen Angriff vorbereiten können?
Also es gibt ja nur die Daten raus.
Na, Ausspähen von Daten ist schon auch ein Angriff. Also in dem Gesetz. Aber das würde ich jetzt hier nicht so deuten wollen.
Ist diese Sorge um die mögliche Straftat, die du da begangen hast, auch ein Grund dafür, dass du dich gerade auf einem Segelboot...
Nein, das ist kein Grund. Das ist einfach nur der jährliche Urlaub.
Verstehe. Okay, also die Frage nochmal ganz konkret beantwortet. Felix, ist X-Fire ein Angriffstool?
Ich würde sagen nein.
Also ich würde auch sagen nein.
Ja, dann leihenlos, Schiff ahoi und nicht über die Boi fahren. Tschüss Martin. Wie mache ich die Nachrichten? Und danach geht es weiter im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Es geht um den Hacker-Paragraphen, Paragraph 202c, Strafgesetzbuch, der sagt, wer Straftaten vorbereitet, indem er Passwörter oder Sicherheitscodes oder Programme herstellt oder zugänglich macht, geht in den Bau. Und zwar für ein Jahr oder es gibt eine Geldstrafe. Und wir sind gerade dabei, diese Formulierung mal zu überprüfen und anhand von Beispielen zu belegen, dass das alles auf sehr, sehr, sehr wackeligen Füßen steht. Mehr dazu gleich hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz.
Ich werde jetzt einen punktgenauen 30-Sekunden-Aufsager hier einsprechen, der mein Programm in einem goldenen Licht dastehen lassen wird.
Fritz präsentiert...
Wasch live. Ich selber ture wieder, die Show heißt bestuhlt. Und nur die ganz, ganz, ganz dämlichen werden nicht erkennen, wie feinsinnig doppeldeutig dieser Titel ist.
Tommy Worsch, live und auf Tour in Berlin und Brandenburg.
Bestuhlt.
Unsere Comedy-Tour 2008 ist eine magische Reise an die Grenzen des menschlichen Verstandes und darüber hinaus.
Wann, wo, wieso, weshalb und warum sowas überhaupt nötig ist.
So, das war jetzt auch wirklich fein. Das könnt ihr einfach ungeschnitten. Wir senden vielen Dank. Nachrichten.
Mit Keitern, natürlich.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die Berliner Regelung zum Rauchverbot in der Gastronomie gekippt. Nach dem Urteil ist Rauchen in Einraumkneipen vorerst unter Auflagen wieder erlaubt. Die Richter sahen die Betroffenen wirte benachteiligt gegenüber den Betreibern größerer Gaststätten, in denen in abgetrennten Räumen geraucht werden darf. Bis Ende 2009 muss das Gesetz geändert werden. Entweder gibt es dann Ausnahmeregelungen für alle oder ein allgemeines Rauchverbot. Verbraucher sollen in Zukunft besser vor unerwünschten Werbeanrufen geschützt werden. Das Bundeskabinett hat heute einen entsprechenden Gesetzentwurf beschlossen. Bei unerlaubter Telefonwerbung drohen Firmen demnach bis zu 50.000 Euro Strafe. Außerdem müssen Callcenter, die ihre Rufnummer unterdrücken, bis zu 10.000 Euro zahlen. Bundestag und Bundesrat müssen noch zustimmen. Chinas Zensur von Internetseiten bei den Olympischen Spielen ist weltweit auf scharfe Proteste gestoßen. US-Präsident Bush forderte China auf, das Internet ohne Beschränkungen freizugeben. Der Vorsitzende des Sportausschusses im Bundestag, Dankhart, ist dafür, die weltweite Fernsehübertragung der Eröffnungsspiele abzusagen, wenn China nicht einlenke. Der CDU-Außenpolitiker Polenz sagte, dass die Hardliner im chinesischen Politbüro sich bestätigt fühlen, wenn die Zensur hingenommen werde. Der Berliner SPD-Chef Müller will den Anstieg der Mieten in Berlin dämpfen. Müller sagte der Online-Ausgabe der Berliner Morgenpost, dass die soziale Mischung erhalten werden solle. So solle Mietspiegel 2009 die Spanne für Erhöhungen eingeschränkt und neue Kriterien wie Verkehrslärm und Energiebedarf der Wohnungen aufgenommen werden. Israels Ministerpräsident Olmert hat seinen Rücktritt angekündigt. Er erklärte am Abend, dass er sich bei der Wahl im September nicht mehr um den Vorsitz der regierenden Kadima-Partei bewerben will. Er stelle dann auch nicht mehr als Regierungschef bereit. Olmert wird Bestechlichkeit vorgeworfen. Er bestreitet das. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, Potsdam-Bittenberg 20°C, Frankfurt-Kotbus-Angermünde 21°C, Neurupien 23°C und in Berlin sind es derzeit 19°C. Heute Nacht ist es nur wenig bewirkt und meist trocken, bei Tieswerten von bis zu 18°C. Morgen gibt es wieder richtiges Sommerwetter. Es gibt viel Sonne. Nur am Nachmittag kann es ein paar wenige Wolken geben und das bei Höchstwerten bis zu 32°C. Mit drei Meldungen auf der A100 Stadtrin Richtung Neukölln-Treptow zwischen Siemensdamm und Spandauer Damm. 1 km Stau. A105 Abzweig-Reinigendorf zwischen Kurt-Schumacher-Platz und Kreuz-Reinigendorf. Dorf ist in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Dort wird eine Brücke abgerissen. Und auf der A111 Stadtautobahn, Stadteinwehr zwischen Heckerdamm und Dreieck Charlottenburg, dort ist gesperrt, auch dort wird gebaut. Sonst eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Dann Fritz in Berlin.
Und ihr seid in Chaosradio mit Tefe, mit Franz und mit Jakob Franz. Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit über den sogenannten Hackerparagraphen zu diskutieren. Und es gibt noch ein paar Dinge, die wir dringend ansprechen müssen, bevor uns die entwickeln.
Ja, denn da ist uns noch ein besonders wichtiger Punkt, eigentlich den wir auch in der Stellungnahme schon ausgeführt haben. Da beziehen wir uns auf dieses neue Grundrecht. Die meisten werden sich vielleicht erinnern, es gab ja die Verhandlung über die Online-Durchsuchung, über das Verfassungsschutzgesetz in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Und da hatte ja Anfang des Jahres das Verfassungsgericht gesagt, okay, so ist das verfassungswidrig, aber wir schenken sozusagen den Bürgern gleich mal ein neues Grundrecht. Das hat ein bisschen sperrige Namen. Das heißt, das Grundrecht auf Gewährleistung der Integrität und Vertraulichkeit von informationstechnischen Systemen. Und wir haben jetzt versucht, uns mal inhaltlich damit ausnahmzusetzen und dann eigentlich zu der Erkenntnis gekommen, wenn wir ein Grundrecht haben, dass unsere Computersysteme, die wir benutzen, integriert sind, dann brauchen wir auch gleichzeitig die Möglichkeit, dass wir sie noch testen können. Und wenn wir selber nicht können, weil wir eben die Fähigkeiten nicht haben, können wir natürlich auch davon ausgehen, dass wir Dienstlässe dafür eben mal uns kaufen können oder uns im Freundeskreis besorgen können.
Das heißt, um es einfacher zu formulieren, dieser Hacker-Paragraph torpediert gerade dieses Grundrecht auf sichere Computersysteme.
So sieht es aus, denn diese Integrität der Computersysteme wurde uns ja gewährleistet mit dem Grundrecht und auch da, also nicht nur im Bereich der Pressefreiheit, der Forschungsfreiheit, der Berufsfreiheit, sondern auch in Bezug auf unser neues Grundrecht, dieses sogenannte IT-Grundrecht, wie die jetzt viele Juristen sagen, ist da betroffen. Da sind wir fest überzeugt von.
Schwein im Raume?
Also haben wir uns auch sehr gefreut, dass sie uns ein neues Recht gegeben haben und dass wir das gleich anwenden konnten.
Die nächste Frage kommt von Lutz, der will nämlich wissen, ob Anti-Spy... Warte mal, danach reden wir mit Alex Konzi. Hallo Lutz. Hallo. Abend. Dieses Thema hatten wir vorhin schon mal, Anti-Spyware, also sozusagen ein Viren-Checker. Ist das auch ein Angriffstool?
Genau. Die Frage ist jetzt ganz speziell, weil ich hatte vor kurzem ein Tool, was sich irgendwie an Anti-Spy nannte und hat sich einfach auf meinen Rechner installiert oder irgendwie ist es auf meinen Rechner gekommen, ohne irgendeine Datei auf der Festplatte zu haben, also zumindest keine fündbare Datei.
Unsichtbar.
Hast du den Ruhken eingefangen?
Keine Ahnung. Also ich habe versucht, also ich habe neu gestartet, dann hat sich das immer wieder neu geladen und wollte mich auf irgendeine Senette verweisen, dass ich es doch freischalte und dann hat es irgendwann meinen Desktop gesperrt, wo die Uhrzeitstandstand alarm und unter dem Startordner alles gesperrt, wo ich auf die Festplatte zugreifen kann. Ich kam nur auch über abgesicherte Modus, Administraterkonto rein und war auch nicht zu finden, das Programm.
Das heißt, deine Daten wurden quasi in Geiselhaft genommen?
Genau, sozusagen.
Dann musst du dir mal eine richtige Anti-Spyware ziehen und im abgesicherten Modus ausführen. Aber können wir dir jetzt auch die Details hier nicht am Radio erzählen. Aber das ist tatsächlich, da hast du dir echt eine Mailware eingefangen.
Denn ich hatte nämlich auch ein paar Mal im abgesicherten Modus Anti-Viren-Programm durchlaufen lassen und hat auch nicht gefunden, komischerweise.
Ja, das ist halt eine eigene Kategorie. Das ist nicht wirklich ein Virus, sondern es ist auch Mailware. Das ist so die Oberkategorie. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich eine Spyware, würde ich sagen. Ja, das ist ein üblicher Trick.
Also eine Spyware, was ich als Anti-Spyware ausgibt, sozusagen.
Genau, das ist ein üblicher Trick, dass irgendwelche Tools versuchen, dir zu suggerieren, du hättest ein Problem und du musst jetzt unbedingt die Vollversion kaufen, sonst ist dein Rechner kaputt. Ja, also das ist häufig, das gibt es häufiger. Und wenn du ein Antivirus nicht findest, kannst du ja mal beim Hersteller beschweren, oder?
Oder einfach einen anderen ausprobieren.
Also ich hab's immer versucht, zu schließen, aber das kam dann immer wieder.
Ja, wie gesagt, also der Tipp im Detail, den können wir jetzt natürlich per Fernwartung auch nicht machen, aber abgesicherten Modus starten, einfach mal was anderes probieren, vielleicht hast du da eine Chance oder aber den Alphanerd deinem Vertrauen fragen. Auf jeden Fall Daumen drücken und viel Glück, Lutz. Danke dir für den Anruf.
Na ja, ich meine nur, Spyware ist ja eine Sache, wo man immer sagen kann, na ja Gott, niemand will das. Und gerade so, du bist ein unbedarfter Benutzer, der von Spyware betroffen ist, das hat echt schon langsam ethische Probleme bei Computern. Spyware will genau niemanden. Ich frage mich, wer das immer überprogrammiert.
Ich glaube übrigens auch, dass Alex, der hier immer anruft, dass Alex auch Spyware ist, weil immer wenn ich Alex rannehmen will, ist er wieder weg. Alex, du kannst gerne nochmal anrufen.
Ja, wir interessieren uns sehr dafür, was du sagen wolltest.
Das weiß aber jetzt sonst noch keiner, deswegen klären wir das erst, wenn Alex anruft und wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Wir haben noch zwei, drei Punkte, die wir auch noch ansprechen wollten. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir hier Däumchen drehen.
Ein wichtiger Punkt, der uns als aktuelles Beispiel eingefallen ist, ist die Myfair-Sache. Wir haben vor wenigen Tagen gerade noch ein aktuelles Gerichtsurteil bekommen, denn es gibt diese Myfair-Ships, das ist mittlerweile sogar schon in der offiziellen Presse, also nicht nur in der Tech-Presse berichtet worden, die vielfach benutzt werden in Europa, meistens für Verkehrsbezahlsysteme, etwa in UK, also in Großbritannien oder in Holland. Und es hat sich bei uns auf dem letzten Kongress, im Dezember letzten Jahres, ein Forscherteam vorgestellt und hat eben gezeigt, dass die hackbar sind und unsicher. Und jetzt ist es dazu gekommen, dass der Hersteller, NXP, der hat sich hingestellt und wollte gerichtlich verhindern lassen, dass die Details dieses Hacks bekannt werden.
Weil dadurch, dass es gehackt wurde, ihr quasi Dinge gemacht habt, die offiziell, also was heißt das, offiziell, die strafbar sind.
Genau. Also die haben nicht ihr Problem fixen wollen, sondern haben halt gedacht, das ist billiger, wenn wir versuchen, die Details geheim zu halten.
Und da sieht man halt auch die Denkweise, die bei Herstellerfirmen von Software oder teilweise im Hardware, die da an den Tag gelegt werden. Das heißt, wir haben auch noch lange Zeit, wenn man jetzt mal so 10, 20 Jahre zurückgeht, gesehen, dass die Hersteller einfach Lücken, die existieren, verleugnen. Das heißt, es wird behauptet, die existieren nicht, aber sie seien nicht so wichtig.
Und solange keiner nachbrücken kann, dass es die gibt.
Genau.
Genau. Und deswegen gibt es überhaupt offene Exploits im Internet.
So sieht es aus.
Das ist historisch nämlich so gewachsen, dass die Hersteller einfach A sich geweigert haben, zuzugeben, dass es eine Lücke gibt. Und B wenn man ihnen nachgewiesen hat, dass es eine Lücke gibt, dann haben sie gesagt, ja ja, fixen wir und haben dann zwei Jahre darauf gesessen. Das passiert teilweise heute immer noch. Und der einzige Weg, was man da tun kann, ist eben, dass man einen Exploit veröffentlicht. Und dann ist quasi bewiesen öffentlich, dass da nicht nur Lücke ist, sondern dass die ausnutzbar ist. Und dann sehen sich die Firmen auch genötigt, mal einen Fix zu machen.
Aber in dem Moment, wo du so einen Exploit veröffentlicht, also wenn du in der Öffentlichkeit darstellst, wie man dieses System hacken kann, befällst du ja optimal unter diesen Paragraphen 203.
Genau. Also das kann man im Moment sehr gut sehen. Gerade heute war auf Heise die Meldung, dass Oracle einen Fix gemacht hat für einen Zero-Day. Das ist genau so ein Exploit, der im Zero-Day heißt, der ist noch nicht publiziert, also für eine Lücke, die vorher nicht bekannt war. Und den haben sie dann auch sofort gefixt. Und üblicherweise macht Oracle das so, dass sie alle viertel Jahre, glaube ich, einen Patch-Day machen, wo sie dann Patches raustun. Und das heißt, wenn man jetzt eine Lücke findet, dann ist die da wahrscheinlich schon jahrelang drin. Und Leute, die schon wussten, dass es die Lücke gab, bevor dieser Exploit veröffentlicht wird, das gibt es ja auch, die konnten das schon seit langem ausnutzen. Aber wenn es dann diesen Exploit gibt, dann ist es also quasi erstens bekannt, dass es ein Problem gibt. Und wenn jemand anderes guckt und nach Problemen sucht, kann es ja sein, dass er genau dieses Problem findet. Aber es gibt eben noch keinen Patch vom Hersteller. Und das machen viele Hersteller so und begründen es damit, dass Firmen ja gar nicht täglich patchen können. Und das ist ja Aufwand und bla bla. Aber in der Praxis ist es eben so, dass einige Firmen, wenn sie nicht gezwungen werden, ihre Sachen zu fixen, dann tun sie es nicht.
Das ist schlicht eine wirtschaftliche Sache. Das ist einfach teuer. Also man kann das klassische Beispiel auch Microsoft nennen.
Es gibt Zahlen von Microsoft, dass die, wenn sie einen Critical Bug haben, also ein Problem, mit dem man ein Wurm schreiben könnte, dann müssen sie den fixen. Und der Fix wird dann über ihr Windows-Update verteilt. Und es gibt also eine interne Qualitätssicherung, die kostet immens Geld. Und das kostet, ich habe jetzt die genauen Zahlen vergessen, ich glaube, 400.000 Dollar für so einen Fix.
Auf jeden Fall, jeder einzelne ist richtig teuer.
Pro Bug. Also natürlich lohnt sich das für Microsoft, wenn sie die Bugs selber finden. Und dann müssen sie keine Patches machen, sondern können es einfach am nächsten Service Pack mit beerdigen. Ja, aber solange keiner weiß, dass es ein Problem ist, sind Hersteller wirtschaftlich daran interessiert, das Problem nicht zu beheben.
Verstehe, weil sie ansonsten, also entweder sie machen es einfach in ihrer Routine und dann ist das sowieso, steht das sowieso auf dem Zettel und kostet Geld. Wenn aber jetzt Fefe kommt und sagt, ihr habt da ein Problem, dann müsste Microsoft darauf reagieren.
Das erhöht einfach die Priorität in der Liste. Man muss sich überlegen, gerade bei großen komplexen Softwareprojekten sind einfach eine ganze Menge Sicherheitslücken. Irgendwie müssen die Hersteller aufgrund des Ressourcenmangels, die haben ja auch nicht eine Million Leute, die da eben Sicherheitslöcher fixen, die müssen priorisieren. Und wenn es einen Exploit gibt, dann ist das mal ganz oben auf der Prioritätenliste. Das ist ein großer Unterschied.
Also wir haben jetzt in den letzten 1 oder 3 Viertelstunden mit vielen verschiedenen unterschiedlichen Beispielen versucht, darzulegen und zu erklären mit euch gemeinsam, warum dieser neue Zusatz zum Hackerparagraphen relativ unsinnig ist und warum alle, die sich damit beschäftigen, von selbst bis zum BSI, warum die alle sagen, dieses Ding ist in der Praxis nicht umsetzbar, trotzdem gibt es dieses Gesetz. Es gibt ja die Diskussion, ob dieses Gesetz wieder abgeschafft wird. Die Frage, die Johann auch stellt, der uns angerufen hat, was passiert denn, wenn dieses Gesetz wieder fällt? Guten Abend, Jonas. Johann.
Hallo. Ja, genau das ist auch meine Frage, was passiert, wenn das Gesetz gekippt wird, wie sieht das für den Endanwender aus? Es kommt ja auch darauf an, wie das Gesetz geändert wird. Es kann ja sein, dass es für Firmen Ausnahmen gibt. Nur ich bin ja auch als Endanwender gespannt, was passiert. Ich will mein eigenes Netzwerk auch sicher halten.
Ja, das wissen wir natürlich auch nicht.
Eigentlich haben wir schon eine klare Ansicht dazu, denn wir stellen uns einfach mal vor, der 202c wird ersatzlos gestrichen. Das heißt A und B bleiben, also abfangen und ausspielen von Daten, und C wird gestrichen. Also wir haben ja lange darüber diskutiert und unsere Ansicht ist eigentlich, es würde genau nichts für den Endanwender passieren, denn alles, was wirklich kriminell ist, war vorher schon und wäre dann auch noch strafbar. Und im Gegenteil, all die negativen Effekte, über die wir heute gesprochen werden, würden halt hinfällig sein. Insofern wäre das nur gut für uns alle, wenn der mal schlicht gestrichen würde.
Was wir halt nicht wissen, ist, ob der wirklich gestrichen wird. Denn das Verfassungsgericht macht es eigentlich nie oder sehr, sehr selten, dass sie sagen, das Gesetz kommt komplett in die Tonne, sondern die sagen eher, das müsst ihr nochmal überarbeiten und hier sind noch ein paar Sachen.
Dann gibt es Veränderungen.
Genau, dann gibt es ein paar kosmetische Veränderungen. Genau. Also nee, sie patchen es ja nicht selber, sondern sie sagen dir, du musst nochmal patchen. Also ja, das ist, was wir hoffen. Die Frage ist nur, wie viel sie bemängeln werden.
Ja, also nach dem Fragenkatalog, den der CCC ja bekommen hat, wir kriegen ja immer so eine Liste vom Gericht, wozu wir uns besonders äußern sollen, also da sind natürlich einige Knackpunkte klar geworden. Mehrere Fragen bezogen sich auf den Zweck der Software. Also wie man etwa mal ganz theoretisch oder zumindest nicht nur an einem praktischen Beispiel, sondern eben über eine Klasse von Programmen sagen kann, ob sie schlecht in dem Sinne sind oder eben gut. Und da haben wir uns natürlich dazu geäußert, denn wir sind tatsächlich zu der Ansicht gelangt, dass man das so pauschal über ein Programm nicht sagen kann, sondern dass am Ende natürlich der Benutzer darüber bestimmt, was der Zweck der Software ist. Denn man muss sich vorhin überlegen, wäre es so, dass man diesen Zweck bestimmen könnte, hätte man glaube ich auch eine andere Form von IT-Sicherheitsforschung heute. Also könnte man das von vornherein anhand technischer Merkmale festmachen, hätten wir sicherlich auch Schadprogramm-Detektoren, die solche typischen Programme einfach filtern würden. Also so wie es nicht die ultimative Schad-Software-Abwehr gibt, gibt es natürlich auch nicht die Programme, die immer nur Schaden anrichten. Das ist glaube ich ein ziemlich, naja, vielleicht auf einer Metaebene eine Weisheit, aber das gibt es halt in der Informationstheoretik nicht wirklich. Der Zweck der Software kann so nicht bestimmt werden.
Auch in der Praxis sieht man das. Wenn es nämlich bestimmbar wäre, dann bräuchte man keine Updates für die Anti-Viren-Signaturen. Ganz plump. Wir haben noch ein Totschlag-Argument, was wir uns bis zum Ende aufgehoben haben. Und zwar für die Leute, die sich noch nicht betroffen fühlen. Der CCC hat unter anderem in Hamburg eine Aktion gehabt, wo die Stadt Hamburg überlegt hat, ob sie nicht mit dem Wahlstift wählen sollen. Und das ist eine Art Wahlmaschine, allerdings nicht in dem Sinne, oder Wahlcomputer ist allerdings nicht in dem Sinne, wie so eine Slotmaschine, sondern das ist so ein Stift mit einer eingebauten Kamera und einem Spezialpapier mit Muster drauf. Und der Stift kann über die Kamera sehen, welches Muster da gerade ist und kann daraus erkennen, an welcher Stelle auf dem Papier man gerade ist. Das ist die Idee. Und damit wollten die ihre Wahlzettel machen und der CCC hat sich das angesehen. Wir haben uns das angeguckt und haben das gebrochen, das System. Wir haben also ein Wahlzettel gemacht unter anderem, wo eben dieses Muster verschoben war, sodass, egal wo man angekreuzt hat, immer dieselbe Partei gekriegt hat. Also das war quasi die große Präsentation. Jedenfalls haben wir unter anderem auf unserer Webseite geschrieben, wir hätten das System gehackt. Die Stadt Hamburg hat inzwischen auch gesagt, sie wollen den Wahlstift nicht mehr einsetzen. Es geht hier also der Kampf um Demokratie in diesem Lande. Und was jetzt gerade passiert, ist, dass die Herstellerfirma, also gar nicht mal der Hersteller, sondern der Reseller, die eigentliche Hardware kommt, wohl von jemand anderem?
Also die sind eine Arbeitsgemeinschaft, die teilweise eben Teile der Software herstellt.
Also die Software haben die auf jeden Fall gemacht, aber wir haben den Stift, den gibt es auch von Logitech oder so.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also sie haben sich eine Hardware, die man auch sonst kaufen kann.
Jedenfalls die Firma, die das verkauft hat, die versucht uns gerade zu verklagen mit der Begründung, weil ihr es gehackt habt. Genau. Und die Frage ist, wie sollen wir denn jetzt nachweisen, dass wir es gehackt haben, wenn das Besitzen oder das zur Verfügung stellen, zum Beispiel dem Gericht von einem Exploit, der das beweisen würde, verboten ist nach dem Hackertool-Gesetz. Das heißt, die Grundfesten unserer Demokratie, um das hier mal ein bisschen pathetisch zu sagen, sind in Gefahr durch den Hackertool-Paragraph.
Na ja, nicht wirklich, weil der Wahrschrift ist ja nur schon, hat sich eigentlich schon erledigt. Also im System der Medien ist es halt ein weniges Beispiel.
Die Art und Weise der Argumentationen ist in dem Fall natürlich deutlich.
So ähnlich wie bei dem verhinzierten Myfair-Problem. Also es versuchen einfach die Hersteller dann auch Leute, die sich mit der Sicherheit befassen, Mundtot zu machen mit ihren Rechtsabteilungen. Also da ist natürlich ein großes Problem.
Und da sieht man mal auch einen Exploit für ein Wahlgerät, was eigentlich ja natürlich einen Schaden erzeugt, also ganz offensichtlich von diesem Gesetz, nicht nur betroffen, sondern gemeint ist, kann auch was Gutes sein. Und zwar für die gesamte Demokratie in diesem Lande.
Johan, ich hoffe deine Frage ist damit erst mal beantwortet.
Wir sind etwas weit abgekommen.
Gibt es eigentlich jetzt noch eine meta-theoretische Frage so Richtung Ende der Sendung. Gibt es eigentlich einen Unterschied, wenn man sagt, Forschung mit Medizin und Forschung mit Technik wird unterschiedlich behandelt, weil dieses Argument, das das Robert-Koch-Institut natürlich irgendwelche gefährlichen Viren und Krankheitserreger hat, die sie untersuchen müssen, da kommt ja auch keiner und sagt, das dürft ihr eigentlich nicht machen.
Na doch, also da gibt es schon Regelungen. Ich darf nicht einfach einen Biokampfstoff zu Hause haben.
Ja, das ist klar.
Oder andere Gefahrstoffe. Da gibt es schon spezielle Regelungen.
Aber niemand fährt da dem Robert-Koch-Institut an die Karre, weil die müssen ja daran forschen.
Genau, also man könnte jetzt, das ist auch eine Sache, die möglicherweise das Verfassungsgericht jetzt sagen könnte, dass sie sagen, wir brauchen für Forschung und Lehre eine Ausnahme oder wir brauchen so eine Art Gefahren gut für Software. Ich hoffe, dass es dazu nicht kommt, genau aus dem Grund, den ich vorhin ausgeführt habe, selbst die Software, die völlig klar gemeint und betroffen ist von dem Gesetz, kann trotzdem gut sein. Also es gibt auch außerhalb von Forschung und Lehre, also auch diese, bei der Wahl kann man ja nicht wirklich von Forschung und Lehre reden, also man kann es konstruieren, aber im Grunde ist es ja nicht Forschung und Lehre, sondern es ist eher der Beweis, dass dieses System unsicher ist. Also uns ging es ja nicht darum, das System zu erforschen, sondern wir wollten zeigen, es ist unsicher.
Wann entscheidet denn das Bundesverfassungsgericht über diesen Paragraphen?
Auch das ist natürlich unklar. Also wir haben jetzt erst vor kurzem die Stellungnahme öffentlich gemacht und kurz vorher dann beim Gericht auch eingeschickt. Es sind noch andere Sachverständige, die dazu Stellung nehmen, also zwei weitere, ist natürlich nicht klar. Wir hoffen natürlich, es schnell geht. Es ist natürlich in der Praxis so, dass jetzt noch nicht so sehr viel passiert ist. Wir sehen natürlich jetzt schon die Auswirkungen so langsam, aber dadurch, dass es noch kein Urteil gibt, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt Gefahr im Verzug.
Aber es hat mir vorhin auch schon beleuchtet, es gibt keinen Urteil, weil das Gesetz sehr schwammig ist, sondern es gibt ein schwammiges Gesetz, weil es keine weiteren Urteile gibt, wo man es festnageln könnte. Also es dreht sich einfach im Kreis.
Ja, solange die Leute nicht in den Knast kommen wegen dem Gesetz, ist mir das ehrlich gesagt recht. Im Moment, ich finde, wir geben denen jetzt ein bisschen Zeit. Das ist auch viel zu warm gerade für so eine behandelnde Urteile, die sollen immer über Raucher entscheiden. Genau. Gebt denen ein bisschen Zeit und Hauptsache Ende gut, alles gut, ist meine Einstellung dazu. Gut.
Das waren etwa zwei Stunden, knapp zwei Stunden Chaosradio. Zum Thema Hackerparagraph. Falls ihr zwischendurch reingeschaltet habt und gesagt habt, ich würde gerne die ganze Sendung hören, das geht natürlich. Die gibt es als Podcast. Einfach entweder fritz.de klicken oder aber ccc.de. chaosradio.ccc.de Man darf immer chaosradio.ccc.de klicken. Man kann auch ccc.de klicken und weiterklicken. Bei ccc.de steht ja auch noch mehr.
Aber eben, denn da muss man sowieso hinklicken, weil jetzt hat man eine Belunte gerochen und will unbedingt die Stellungnahme mal am Ganzen lesen. Das kann man tun.
Nichts ist spannender als Gesetzestexte kurz vor dem Schlafengehen.
Das ist kein Gesetzestext.
Nein, also wir haben versucht, unsere Stellungnahme nicht einschläfernd zu machen und sie ist auch so kurz, wie es irgendwie ging.
Das kann man noch mal eben lesen. Also, das liest sich ganz schnell.
chaosradio.ccc.de oder aber ccc.de oder aber fritz.de oder aber blog.fifel.de gibt es noch.
Ein winziges Detail noch. Der Kongress findet dieses Jahr wieder statt und der Call for Papers ist gerade veröffentlicht worden. Also, wenn einer von uns sich berufen fühlt, beim CCC-Kongress nicht nur als Besucher, sondern auch als Redner aufzutreten, dann könnt ihr gerne...
Wenn wir zum Beispiel fähigen Juristen, der sich gerne vor den Hackern mal so richtig tiefschürfende Gedanken, juristischer Art, über den Hackerparagraphen machen will. Und wenn man übrigens zu chaosradio.ccc.de geklickt hat, dann kann man ja auch mal nach Chaosradio Express klicken. Wir haben nämlich neben dieser Radiosendung auch immer noch den Podcast. Der ist ein bisschen geekiger, aber Tim produziert da eine große Menge an sehr interessanten Themen. Es lohnt sich immer, da hinzuklicken.
So, mehr Werbung müssen wir jetzt nicht machen. Wir wünschen euch einen großartigen Juli. Wir hören uns in vier Wochen wieder. Der Juli ist noch nicht vorbei.
Ja, aber der Ausdruck kommt eine Woche früher.
Chaosradio kommt nämlich im August eine Woche früher, weil die Games Convention schon stattfindet und die Gamechecker gesagt haben, wir müssen auf jeden Fall nach der Games Convention eine Sendung machen. Deswegen ziehen wir eine Woche vor. Ich glaube, es ist der 20. oder so. Fritz.de klicken, da steht alles drauf. Hier geht es gleich weiter mit Maxwell Smart und dem Night Flight. Der hat Milliarden Gäste da draußen rumzuliegen, die alle irgendwelche Platten mitbringen. Das wird sehr, sehr abgefahren. Fefel, Konz und Jakob sagen Tschüss, war schön gewesen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.